for people who want to have a baby false
messages about fertility can be
especially powerful so I want to say
upfront that the covid-19 vaccine is
safe for fertility
the data on this is clear covid-19
vaccination saves lives for everyone
especially pregnant people and their
babies but the fog of the pandemic has
made it extra challenging to dispel the
misinformation surrounding the covid-19
vaccine so I want to address some of
these worries by talking about how a
vaccine becomes a vaccine in the first
place to show that each step of creating
the vaccine is closely evaluated for
safety one of the early stages of
vaccine development involves exploratory
research in the case of the coronavirus
that causes covid-19 researchers already
had years of knowledge and insight to
work from scientists already knew a lot
about other coronaviruses and because of
knowledge sharing they were able to
Simply download the virus's genetic code
off a website they were also able to
take advantage of the advances made in
mRNA vaccine technology which you might
have heard about while mRNA vaccines are
new to the public researchers have been
studying and working with them for
decades I want to underscore this point
one worry about the vaccine is that it
felt rushed but while the covid-19
vaccine was developed rapidly its
creation was based on Decades of
research once the exploratory stage is
finished researchers move on to the
pre-clinical stage where testing is done
done in Petri dishes or on animals the
goal of pre-clinical tests is to see if
the vaccine truly works on the pathogen
in this case the virus that causes
covid-19 and also to test the safety of
a vaccine this is where researchers
perform toxicity testing using a dosage
far greater than what they might use in
humans to make sure it's safe by testing
on animals they're able to see if
vaccines have any impact on functions
like the reproductive system you might
be surprised to learn that the chemical
signaling that happens in a rat uterus
is very similar to what happens in a
human uterus here's what's important
researchers don't move on from the
pre-clinical testing phase until they
prove that the vaccine is unlikely to
harm anyone this is a rigorous process
that goes through FDA approval once the
FDA approves the next step is the
clinical development or clinical trials
testing in humans which is a three-phase
process phase one starts with a small
group of people usually less than 100
very healthy adults by phase three
researchers are working with thousands
or even tens of thousands of people
because of the urgency of covid-19
researchers save time by overlapping
these phases using early data from each
phase to design for the next in other
words no steps were skipped now it's
true that clinical trials for the
covid-19 vaccines didn't include
pregnant people and that's not unusual
pregnant people are currently part of a
protected class that typically aren't
included in testing new vaccines or new
drugs I completely understand the
worries around this but remember testing
in animals is a proven way to ensure
vaccine safety the pre-clinical data for
the covid-19 MRNA vaccine showed no
impact on fertility in animals that
would lead researchers to suspect there
would be issues with humans even after
the vaccine has been approved by the FDA
and made available to the public there's
still work to be done these are called
phase 4 trials where researchers and
Regulatory Agencies track how the public
responds to the vaccine long term
monitoring side effects collecting and
analyzing data from a much wider
population and now we have even more
data to reassure us about fertility
after the kova 19 vaccine was rolled out
there were reports online of people
experiencing irregular periods or
changes in their menstrual cycle this
understandably made people nervous about
a potential effect on fertility or an
unknown effect of the vaccine we didn't
have any data about irregular menstrual
cycles from clinical trials to point to
and that is problematic but given the
rush to get the data it would have been
hard to collect because people would
have had to track Cycles before the
vaccine differences people notice in
their menstrual cycles are valid and
it's scary and uncertain to notice a
change in our bodies and because the
endometrium the lining of the uterus
that sheds during a period is part of
our immune system it is theoretically
possible a vaccine could have a
temporary effect in the same way a
vaccine causes temporary swelling in the
lymph nodes for some people or a
temporary fever researchers responded to
the concerns raised online and looked
into Data from almost 4 000 people who
tracked their Cycles using an app and
compared data from the vaccinated group
to those who didn't get vaccinated on
average the menstrual cycles of people
who were vaccinated varied in length by
less than one day which is interesting
but not medically significant since
normal menstrual cycles vary by up to
seven days each cycle the only group
that was more likely to show a
meaningful difference in their menstrual
cycle length were those who received two
doses of the vaccine in one cycle even
then what they observed was temporary
their Cycles went back to normal within
three cycles and we've continued to
gather data we now see the importance of
vaccination for those who are pregnant
as the risk of mortality in pregnancy
with covid-19 is 1.6 percent that's 22
times higher than the risk of mortality
in pregnancy for those without covid and
unvaccinated mothers and pregnant people
who do get coveted 19 have a much higher
chance of being admitted to the
Intensive Care Unit we also now have
data showing that infants from people
vaccinated during pregnancy do have
antibodies to help protect them from
covid-19 if your goal is a healthy
pregnancy one of the best ways to
achieve that is by getting vaccinated
and we can have confidence that the kova
19 vaccines have been rigorously tested
and are being closely followed
[Music]